it was a magical time full of wine and
horrifying insults it's time for roses
and rose say hi you guys it's me Lauren
Zima wearing a better outfit this week
last week I was kind of a mess kind of
like The Bachelor I mean in the best way
cuz it's the mess that we love a hot
mess that's actually hot and this week
I'm feeling a little hotter I went for a
more basic black shirt I've got a big
eyelash on I don't know what you guys do
if you sort of have little beauty armor
pieces that you wear if you're not
feeling great for me it's a big lash an
eye workout it's a weight on my eye
anyway I am so happy to be back with all
of you to discuss the latest episode of
Colton Underwood season of The Bachelor
I loved this episode you guys what did
you think overall a great app and wow
wow wow this season continues to delay
so let's jump right in of course we're
back with a selfie blog it's pretty much
Katy told me there's still someone or
some people here that aren't ready
so what call the selfie vlog really put
in perspective for me was why didn't he
ask the women who were leaving with all
those ominous warnings who they were
talking about the whole selfie vlog was
about how he still didn't know who to
trust you had three women leave and tell
you that women there didn't have good
intentions why don't you say are you
talking about vlog so yeah I didn't
understand it get a name called you know
be a better detective
Denver's Colton's hometown and his
homegirls I'm sorry we're dressing very
monochromatic ly I was wondering if this
episode was styled a little more than
usual they were in like basic black and
pink and like more basic black it was
just they all looked like they were
coming out of a catalog as they came
into Denver are you doing and then we
have Ben Higgins and you know what drink
every time somebody's color-coordinated
because Ben and Colton were kind of both
color-coordinated mm-hmm really reaching
for excuses to drink at this point
aren't I so it's Ben and Ben is stacking
papers at a bar because Ben is a small
business owner now I think that's what
that's indicating so Colton and Ben have
one of those former bachelor to new
bachelor heart-to-hearts and as a
reminder it's fairly sensible because
Ben does live in Denver I think they've
hung out a little bit I had an idea that
I would come in and I would know like
night one here's who I'm into like now
I'm falling in love with multiple people
you know I liked Colton acknowledging
that he thought he would know from night
one who he was in to remember he gave
Hanna ji the first impression rose but
he has lots of other strong feelings for
the other women and I liked him sort of
saying look I kind of went into this
thinking I was gonna know and then just
go through the process but I don't know
now what did you guys think how do you
feel about Colton's feelings at this
point do you think that they are real do
you think that they are clear let me
know my only advice now is lean in be
intentional and you know Ben pulls a
sheryl sandberg and says lean in we
didn't be intentional Kalinin lean into
the process into owning a small business
and then the ladies beat Colton and a
dog at a park and actually the dates
begin right now
and then he just takes a shot a date
tisha would you like to join me and get
out of here
I know that I was season long I've been
saying have you guys watched the show
ladies have you watched the show because
they don't like when the women get upset
like I can't believe she got a
one-on-one or wow how many roses are
left it's like this is the way the show
goes but on this one man I would have
felt burned if I were them
they got all dressed up in their subtle
tones to go to this park and then Colton
just takes Taoiseach on a date by E Wow
okay I mean if I'm Hannah B I'm like
alright I was wearing this bra top with
a see-through mesh overlay for nothing
what very rude this is like what I was
doing a casual Saturday
Taoiseach and Colton's date you guys oh
my god this is my dream date except
there's not a hot tub in a cold
environment which is very much my dream
date but they had oysters and they had
wine and of course it's in a market and
then they got ice cream and then wine oh
my god drink some snacks there we go
what a date but then we've got to get
into the drama because things are going
too smoothly and Colton he trusts her
opinion he doesn't question her and so
he wants to know who he should question
[Music]
hear what you heard
but before we get that information we've
got to cut back to Kalin and Cassie and
they are saying that it wasn't fair that
these three woman would just like drop
these bombs on him as they leave be
careful
Dominus I'm reaching I'm sorry drink for
another stupid punim hmm so I'm
wondering why they go back to Kalin and
Cassie well then that's answer feel like
caffeine Halen
Taoiseach just lays into it and names
Kaylin and Cassie as the women who are
not ready for marriage
who are not there for the right reasons
they're always talking about and who
have ulterior motives they've also said
that literally
you'd be ready to get engaged
ah drink for every horrifying allegation
the Taoiseach made hmm
were you guys shocked by how much she
just dove right in
she was saying that Kalyan and Cassie
are not genuine and golden did not look
like he liked tearing that his face was
like crap I'm most into that that's how
it read to me it was so intense that it
didn't ring totally true to me it felt
to me like she was kind of throwing our
competition under the bus what did you
guys think did you believe everything
tatius said or did it seem like too much
this is one of those moments or it
drives me nuts because tisha is
referring to like some conversations
some things they've said and it's like
you know they film everything you know
they could roll the tape that I wouldn't
see what happens like cool me figure it
out for himself I wonder if the leads
just ever so frustrated with the
producers that he says would you roll
the tape rather tape Rob a tape there
was one always marker things that
doesn't make sense
anyways cooled and gets this news and he
is bending over in his idea I'm like
he's gonna go throw up and like I have
to say I threw up last weekend it's
horrible
he was very trying to puke as an adult
isn't it I felt so childlike I didn't
know what was going on I didn't remember
how to throw up confusing I don't
recommend it I was sick so and then he's
like
can you or are you gonna throw up you're
just really doubling over so Coleman
says you know again this was my greatest
fear and don't drink every time Colton
says that this episode I'm just scared
my ultimate fear in all of this really
familiar
this was my greatest fear what do you
guys think of Colton's greatest fear I'm
not sure how to feel about it because
what's interesting to me and I wonder if
this stems from it is that when Colton
became the bachelor what a lot of people
questioned was is he ready and now his
greatest fear is someone who isn't ready
I kind of think it's maybe it's
triggering for him let me know so more
of tation Colton's amazing date though
it took a turn their cooking I think
today is really special tables really
nice
I've been sending my subpoenas and
baking and broiling amara where I wanna
open line yay okay I'm just saying was
this the most normal date ever in the
history of The Bachelor I don't remember
the last time we saw someone cooking
like at an apartment with a date it's
very normal so interesting I mean I
think teaches great but back to the
ladies all season long I've really been
missing the clarification on where they
are these different locations I don't
think this house has ever explained it
looks kind of like Hogwarts to me it's
very fantastical I bet about boots
eyestrain layers and with levels and
tourism it's just it's very awkward to
me I guess I'm a cockney wizard isn't
everything my British accents are
questionable at best so at this point
everyone has had a one-on-one and now
it's about are you getting a second
one-on-one are you on the group date
even though the group is dwindling the
date card comes in and gala gets the
one-on-one Kaelyn then don't drink every
time someone's crying about this they
all really lost it mhmmm but we see
Cassie and kaylynn's friendship really
come out in this episode right because
Cassie was very supportive of Kaelyn
she's like through tears like I hate it
I'm glad you got it it was very
sister-wives to me ever watch that TLC
show you're trying to be best friends
with the woman who has a relationship
with your husband oh my god they are
sister wives it's like they love each
other but they also love the same man a
lot to unpack there
I can't take it on back to tation Colton
in the fun wine date and tisha gets a
rose great and then it's Kailyn and
Colton's dates very quickly and oh my
god this date conversely is my nightmare
having to learn to snowboard to learn a
sport on a date
a cold sport where you might fall down
oh my god I think you and you are on a
mountain the wine is very far away I
mean there are certain sports like golf
and tennis where I'm like the wine is
nearby
I see the clubhouse oh god it's my
nightmare mmm but luckily we blew right
through it we barely saw it we got a lot
more of tation Colton's date with Kayla
and Colton we went store right to the
drama and Colton confronts Kailyn with
what tatius said she thought that you
were one of the women that wasn't quite
ready and tell me what you guys thought
of Kalin's reaction because I think it's
one of those moments where like you know
when you analyze how someone's reacting
in court when they're like on trial for
crime and you're wondering if they
really did it or not and you're looking
at everything about their face Kalyn
looked a little blank but I think she
was incredibly caught off guard and it
was my read that she was kind of trying
to figure out what to say because she
suddenly became stuck in this difficult
situation of she-said she-said where
tisha has said something about her and
all she can do is defend herself and
it's a horrible situation where there is
no evidence in this case it's another
round of pageant gait it's pageant gait
round two like Kaylin and Hannah now
it's Kailyn and tisha and I want
specific examples and I want exhibits
and I want quotes but we're not gonna
get any of that here today an opinion is
gonna be mixed up with fact and it's
gonna be a big cluster but that makes
for good television doesn't it okay so
I understood Kaitlyn's frustration and
then oh damn
Kaelyn called Taoiseach stupid I will
call that stupid [ __ ] at wheat meat out
of saying that jay-z but oh my god she
called her stupid beep oh that's a lot
even for this show hmm what do you guys
think - Kaelyn take it too far
when was that insult incredibly
appropriate well Caitlin : luckily
survives snow morning and now they're
getting dinner which is much more my
speed and Kaelyn tells Colton that she's
falling in love with him
I gotta say I think she had to Tasha had
called her into question so much she had
to really show and tell Colton that she
was serious so how do you feel do you
think that Kaitlyn really is falling in
love with Colton Colton then tells
kennedys falling in love with her oh my
god it seems Barry's it's so funny isn't
it have you guys ever told someone you
were falling in love with them I have
never told someone not he just always
goes from like dating - were in love
that falling in love thing I really
credit the bachelor franchise for like
cultivating this step in a relationship
I'm falling in love with you what I did
feel today was that Kaitlyn cares bro
she is ready and she is here for me and
she is here at the end of this to walk
away engaged
bottom line Colton comes away from this
date saying he knows that Kalyan is
ready so my question is does that mean
you think tisha is a liar what do you
think cuz you already get a shy rose and
now Kane also has a rose and these two
have really that's people fighting back
to the ladies and Hanabi gets a
one-on-one I was a little surprised by
this for you guys I did not think you'll
be Hanabi I kind of thought it would be
Cassie cuz I think quote was really into
her but we know what happens the enemy
it gotta make sense okay how can you
live with yourself and be this vacant as
nasty that no but very quickly we've got
to get more drama Kaelin confronts
Taoiseach hey three-time hey yeah and
she's like I can't even deal with it
hey I can't even deal with it and
teachers like the way the Taoiseach was
listening to her was really funny to me
cuz Kalin's like you stupid B I can't
deal with the teachers like just saying
good listening skills did I have any
plans of talking about you know
Colton asked me a question and I told
him my opinion and then Taoiseach really
went off the rails for me how did you
feel about her response I did not trust
it I felt that with golden tisha had
been saying I heard them say these
things and then with Kalyn all of a
sudden Taoiseach was saying well it's my
opinion that you guys the fact vs. the
opinion got very murky and muddy to me
if I really like want to talk smack
about you I would be talking smack about
you every single day and it's very
questionable and I am skeptical and
drink every time I say a word that ends
in both recital
varietal I don't have anymore I'm done
okay then we get calls one-on-one with
Hannah and he brings her home to meet
the family
okay so I'm confused on Colin's family I
know his parents are divorced I don't
know who his mom or stepdad or his dad
or whatever it's like I need name tags
can we give them nametags I'm just
confused but it doesn't matter because
family swim in love is love so dad
guitar yeah is incredible while we were
in Thailand she told me that she was
falling in love with me I'm not there
yet
Colton you just brought her here to meet
your whole family man but I think that's
what it was I think he brought Hannah
home to see how real are my feelings for
her it turns out they are not there this
felt like the nail in the Hanabi coffin
didn't it when he told his dad that I
mean we knew what was coming
what's your gut tell you right now
[Music]
so are you in love with Colton yes and
then Hannah tells Colton's mom she's in
love with him not just falling off and
that's gonna make this all someone's
work painful because we know what's
coming did you guys see what was coming
at this point the second potent said
that to his dad I felt that I saw what
was coming a side note though I loved
Hannah's accent and could listen to it
all day yes it's there
Alabama here she's just got a real cute
accent doesn't she yes also side note
Colton's now drinking red wine with his
dad and you know what I love Colin's
diversity and wine choices this episode
he's had a wife he's had a sham he's had
a red I love a shard I love a sham I
love up in Anwar so you know what cheers
to all the side notes into all the wine
mmm he just accidentally almost blew my
nose in this wine Wow okay it's very on
brand guys my brand is elevated ratchet
that's about all I can say for myself
you look beautiful now we're the
nighttime portion of the date and Hannah
is like pretty cool I got a hotel before
I'm down and it's one of those dates
where you know they jar just so not on
the same page and is going to be so
painful to watch but we love that as
fans don't me or messed up okay I've
turned in southern because I and Hannah
is wearing this like 80s shoulder-padded
pretty and pink dress moment it is very
steel magnolias to me when paired with
her southern accent and I love that
movie
you should broaden your horizon you
broaden your horizons your way and ila
broaden my horizons man yeah hit Ouisa
here hit I won't say who but I'm about
to get mad so she tell us Colton she's
falling in love with him leaving in love
with you soon even though she told her
mom she was straight-up in love with him
and we can feel the breakup coming right
because she's like I want you to meet my
mom and dad and he's like I want to say
thank you thank you and I appreciated
that more than you'll ever know when
someone says thank you you know what
that means
no thank you he's like no that's really
what he's saying I don't want to meet
your mom and dad and before you know it
Colton's broken up with her I don't know
there was that breakup quick I'm not
even sure was clear it was just that
they both knew but he didn't actually
say I'm breaking up with you it was a
lot to take in and it was fast and it
was over and it was dark and it was deep
and we're far from the show
[Music]
aren't you tired try to feel that
I had to do it I'm done so we're done he
just introduced her to his parents and
then he dumped her and I would be like I
put on my Steel Magnolias dresses I
should have saved it for something else
here hit this poor Hannah she's been
dressing up all episode for nothing and
she looks great and cool and says I know
that I shocked him but you know what
Colton could you have given her an
apology this is the first time in this
season that I've been frustrated with
Colton the very first time cool you
should have said Hanna I know that I
blindsided you correction you should
have said Hanna I know that I blindsided
you and I'm sorry okay
and and Shelby drink your juice
you need some juices a cold drink your
wine whether it's a something y'all
Blanc or a Cabernet or Merlot or a dry
brut champagne or a champagne that's a
rose a which is what I have today how
did you guys feel about the break-up
with Hanna how'd you feel
thanks to motions me to obviously and
then oh my god
Hanna B Lee was with a warning about the
other women
I'm over the warnings I have nothing to
say about it
I'm done he still didn't ask her who she
was talking about I'm over it it's like
the season of warnings that now mean
nothing it's like when someone's like
man overboard and you're like Cara is
there a man overboard what do we need to
do here be clear
sorry that was a below deck reference I
hope you guys watch that show but I love
it
Man Overboard none of it was okay the
group date is happening and oh my god do
not drink every time it is dead silent
in that limo
and did you guys feel that this group
date rang a little false because here's
the thing it's Cassie panna Koopa and
Heather and we have seen on one-on-ones
Colton be like crazy for Cassie super
amounts of chemistry with Hannah G kirpa
he was a little iffy on Heather he's a
little iffy on so this date seems
already very clearly divided to me and
like we know how it's gonna go I'm a
side note I like Cassie's red sweater
I like all things read something for
color okay they're somewhere they're in
a limo and then someone says look at
that little bridge thing and it's like
that's a bridge where this date was or
what was going on like all of a sudden
they were in the woods like talking but
did they ever explain that train look
they're all like why are we on that
train where our fee is this Narnia
what's happening and so they're in the
woods we don't know why or where or how
or when or who and Colton says if you
are going to introduce me to your family
that you feel confident and where we're
at only introduce me to your family if
you feel confident about where we're at
well Coleman why did you introduce
Hannah B to your family Colton I love
you but I was annoyed with you I was
annoyed with you I don't know where this
X is from and I'm sorry if it's bad
don't know where's accent from I'm sorry
if it's bad I've gotta stop myself right
now I just don't
think that it's fair to you to take you
to a hometown god this is the episode of
things happening quickly out of nowhere
Heather is exiting stage left heather
has pieced out and she is like I'm done
we are not there I got to go and I gotta
give her credit good for you Heather
see you on paradise cheers to either
tell me what you think about his exit
but I was here for it mmm she got her
first kiss and she said see you later
miss her okay the women are dropping
like flies this season at this point
aren't they guys like a lot of women
have left of their own volition which is
really interesting did you have any
thoughts on that or and why let me know
I don't have a theory I don't I'm not on
this one I don't know why the women are
like Sydney and Heather and I've I had
too much wine did you hear she's getting
on
the Mystery Train becomes a part of it
all again like they hear it whistling in
the distance and everyone's like is she
getting on the train and they can hear
the church this magical land and it's
like what is this are we in Narnia what
oh I just realized it's the Hogwarts
Express it's taking her back to Hogwarts
[Music]
I'm nervous about the whole Asia Kaitlyn
thing I don't want that to like follow
me I heard about it kirpan and Cassie
are now talking and kirpa space is very
pinched up and angry and creepers raids
how Colton a lot of things and in
Cassie's face is also getting pinched up
and response to that and we are matching
each other with our anger
I think Cassie's still trying to find
herself a little bit in life I just
don't think she's ready for his lifelong
commitment and Kripa has her opinions
ready and this is paget gate route 2 and
I need facts because it's just her
opinions and sign-out Cassie's really
pretty
it's all I got I like looking at her
face
I don't want Gillian Cassie to screw him
over at the end of this Soaker pond
Colton go to talk and she says that her
big evidence that Cassie and Kalyn are
not ready for this is that they were
defensive in a conversation they were
the only two girls that started to panic
and they got very defensive and again
it's like can you just give me one
direct quote on anything anyone says and
then I realized that when Garba and
Colton were talking she had a pink
notebook and then they walked away and
the pink notebook was never explained
nothing with kirpa has ever explained
she can fall on her face and hurt her
chin she can bring her notebook full of
her manifestos and it's just never
explained so you know what that
indicates to me Cerf about to leave
that's what my read on that was we don't
care enough to explain things well she's
going home why would you go spend your
time talking to Colton about me I think
he needs to know all the know but a lie
it's not a lot anyway Cassie and kirpa
are then fighting and honestly at this
point I'm annoyed watching this because
I don't know what they're talking about
everyone's defensive everyone's she said
she's setting there's a lot of
allegations flying around kirpa is
claiming red flags I know we are in a
magical land but we need tangible things
okay then Colton says he is I don't know
exactly what I want to do yet with the
two biggest roses and we didn't even see
him dr. Hanna which actually indicated
to me that Hanna's probably good to go
so I want to give myself a cheers for
predicting this episode's pretty well
I'm not done great previously this
season
you say we get on out of here Golden's
like let's get out of here and it's like
where where are we where is here and we
are we going everyone had to platform 9
and 3/4 I am the most ratchet was hurt I
took a test once and I was in the
Griffon doll but I think I'm a briefing
though with a ravenclaw rising because
sometimes I think I'm clever and funny
my Slytherin no Hufflepuff mi home I say
like this my friends it isn't a spell
anyway and then back to Hogwarts where
Kalyn and tisha are cooking up some
potions and then Kahlan says she will
not like it if cassia sent home which I
thought was a benign comment and I could
not see what was coming so nevermind I
am bad at predicting I'm nothing what
was that character in Harry Potter I
predicted things she read the tea leaves
a comment I don't remember I think she
was played by that British actress in
the movie that doesn't help they're all
British ok so back to the group date and
oh my god Caitlyn is walking through the
night in her jean jacket I would have
put on a different outfit it's a very
daytime look but how did you get there
so quickly did she operate and she is
there I'm so confused on where this
group date was in relation to Hogwarts
did they come in on that boat from the
Goblet of Fire book and when she walked
in how did she know where to find Colton
was it like Accio Colton yes I do have a
Harry Potter wand in my desk at work ah
well oh yeah you know the speed where
you out cold where was the group date
where's Hogwarts and where the girls and
where to Kaitlyn walk in her jean jacket
where was it
did you get a puppy on the way why am i
a chimney-sweep wizard well in this
accent
don't be Harry Potter sir I'm Toby
that's what I am I'm Dobie Dobie so it's
very weird Kalin walks in and then walks
out without saying hi to kirpa and
Cassie at all and it's just so socially
odd but also we're on a reality show
or maybe she thought she was wearing an
invisibility cloak I don't know oh yeah
how are you okay we don't actually see
what Kaelyn told Colton in defense of
Cassie but I guess he's made a decision
did she give him some kind of potion and
Coleman picks up the rose like it's a
wand and he is no longer a muggle and I
have and the Cole says he's realized
that tonight I have to continue to trust
my guy all my heart or about what
Caitlin told him
[Music]
next week on The Bachelor okay so then
the teaser happens and honestly I don't
even know what's in the teaser I'm so
ready for this fence jumping moment
which they didn't actually put in the
teaser this week and I thought it was
going to be in this week's episode so I
was wrong on that as well and so I need
to work on my magic what is it what is
the name of a person who can predict
stuff in Harry Potter this is gonna
drive me nuts
divination I just remembered it's
divination that's what I need to work on
I need to study harder in divination you
are in grave danger that was this week's
episode everybody I still have more wine
disappearo always graceful elevated
ratchet thank you guys so much for
watching as always I love love love love
you and by the way when I was feeling a
little down and a little sick last week
so many of you sent me nice messages and
I really appreciate that and they love
love love love love you and hope
everyone had a great Valentine's Day
full of love and remember that in the
words of Carrie Bradshaw I think the
most important relationship you have is
the one you have with yourself I just
blew that kiss like it was a spell okay
I love you guys let me know you got it
the episode we are winding down it's all
happening it's all coming to an end I
don't want this season to come to an end
they love it so much Harry Potter I
don't want the books the end although I
used to be the loser girl who was a
bombed Noble book party for the book
release making wormed out of a piece of
pipe cleaner
and in reading for the book to come so I
could get it and then my parents said
the girl wanna buy two books your sister
gonna share and so we had to read it
together but she's a faster reader so I
was like really behind and that's where
my favorite book is the Goblet
appearances okay love you guys thank you
so much bye e all right guys the truth
is I actually have three ones on my desk
you do this every time there's something
to cover for Harry Potter a TT i asked
her if i can cover it cover the opening
of the park here in LA and also the
movie fantastic beasts nor to find them
depend on rose guardians or yes up its
Leviosa ready
ratchet young
[Music]
[Laughter]
but I just wanted to take another look
at you I finally figured out how to do a
posh accent so as always thank you all
so much for watching bye